[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
a comedy podcast about death hosted by
myself John Green and not my brother
Hank green who is on tour but instead my
mom
Sydney green hi there John Green hi
how's it going it's going pretty well
already sort of missing Hank but Nicaea
I also miss Hank but I'm very glad to
have you here as a guest so the way it
works in this podcast is we answer your
questions we provide you dubious advice
and we give you all the week's news from
both the AFC wimbledon and this week not
news from mars but instead a recipe yes
i'm very excited about the recipe i am
too because i just ate it for dinner
last night and i thought it was
delicious
i know it was delicious who knew so how
are you doing mom I'm doing I'm doing
well I'm glad to be here in Indiana it's
a beautiful summer spring day it's good
to see the grandchildren yeah nice to
see you we're excited about the Indy 500
we're very excited about the Indy 500 I
picked out my guys who even know their
names - who are you guys hey you know I
I have a personal love for men montoya
just because of the Princess Bride
I know Montoya connection yes exactly
and if not him I do like Simon just
because he gave you such a hard time in
the Grand Prix when I drove the pace car
at the Grand Prix of Indianapolis
Simon passion Oh with whom I am
personally acquainted kept riding my
bumper he kept I don't know if he was
just trying to warm up his tires or if
he wasn't satisfied with the speed at
which the pace car was being driven but
he kept roaring up right up to my bumper
Oh who's frightening I know so I sort of
kind of liked the idea so you like him
and and then you know you can't help but
not like the pole
guy oh yeah James Hinchcliffe yeah story
he's an amazing guy really great what a
lovely person
very generous does tons of work in the
community here in Indianapolis so of
course when this podcast is being
actually listened to the Indianapolis
500 will be in the
yes so you know sting who we picked if
we picked correctly right well let's
hope that it's James James Hinchcliffe
yep
Juan Pablo Montoya yep or the Simon
Pan's you know yes that's who you're
rooting for that's why I'm ringing for
you do you have similar or different I
have an IndyCar fantasy league so I for
the drivers that ended up in my fantasy
league which this year means Takuma Sato
Jack Hawksworth Ryan hunter-reay and
Elio Castroneves but I have a personal
affection for skeptics and so I also be
very yes yeah he's a good guy too
yeah I know that's what people come to
this podcast for mommy I do too is Indy
500 analysis after the Indy 500 has
occurred that sounds perfect it's a
great podcast so mom before we get to
listener questions I'm just hoping you
can comment on something that happened
in a recent episode of dear Hank and
John which is that my brother apologized
for having destroyed
Tuggle the the cookie jar that in fact
is not destroyed and is still living
happily with you and dad in Western
North Carolina that's correct so tell us
what actually happened well what
actually happened was you destroyed well
Hank destroyed my last remnant of my
college life oh wow so you had a cookie
jar all the way from college yes that
what my one of my boyfriend's had made
and gave it was his senior project and
he gave it to me and and hey broke that
so I cried some just because that was
the end of my college career this is
like the last remnant last you had that
was it and then it broke yeah well it's
interesting that you mentioned that
because I thought we might start with a
question about adulthood and what
adulthood means I'm gonna be reading all
the questions because I have the
computer oh wait mom I forgot about the
short poem you did I was wondering
alright very excited about that I do
have a short poem you'll never guess
what it's about uh death it's about
death you're correct
it's a beautiful short poem by Langston
Hughes one of the all-time best short
poets in my opinion you wrote this poem
is actually just called poem
I loved my friend he went away from me
there's nothing more to say the poem
ends soft as it began
I loved my friend oh it might not be
about death it might just be about a
friend breakup but it's very sad isn't
it it is very sad
I love the poem and soft as it began I
did - oh he's good he's good hey maybe
you'll keep that one for my funeral oh
goodness gracious must I must we go
there well I don't know it's a podcast
about death now people are seeing where
I got the obsession from ok alright so
we are gonna try to answer this question
about so-called proper adulthood this
question comes from Jade who asks dear
John and Hank a few times in the podcast
you have referred to proper adults
trademark and I'm curious how do you
define adult I'm assuming that adulthood
is a scale perhaps weighing age and
experience not a binary do you agree am
i a 25 year old woman with an office job
before a 1k and great workplace benefits
more adult than my identical twin sister
who is a second-year law student does it
matter that I am a minute older what do
you think mom well you know I'm still
candidly thinking about the fact that my
adulthood started when you guys broke my
guitar so so the answer I think mom's
answer is that adulthood begins when the
last memory of your college boyfriend is
destroyed by your children yeah there's
something to that isn't it yeah or I I
feel like both you and your sister
probably are right there in adulthood
yeah I think you're just making the
transition it's a what in my opinion
it's a long transition and it ends when
you can no longer plausibly say that you
are not an adult you know I think that's
true yeah and there just comes a day
when you look up and you realize that
you are definitely not not an adult
yeah and therefore you must be an adult
yes have you reached that stage for me
the critical moment looking back was
when I put
an outfit I've talked about this before
on the podcast and Sarah was with me and
I said I just feel like I look like a
middle-aged man in this outfit and Sarah
paused for just like one second too long
and I realized that it had happened yeah
yeah but for you it was the destruction
in the cookie jar
yes now you know why I cried so hard and
why you guys even though your toe so
little you remember it it is a very
intense memory for me although a faulty
one since Hank and I both thought that
we'd destroyed Tuggle and the cookie jar
that was shaped like a tugboat which is
in fact in perfect condition yes it is
well the nose has been rubbed the pain
has been rubbed away from the nose well
but still compared to this the college
boyfriend cookie jar it's in great shape
yes Troy so adulthood in short is a is a
process not an event but it is marked by
events perhaps Oh beautifully said yes
thanks mom
you're welcome you should always co-host
this podcast we've got another question
this one comes from Lauren who writes
Dear John and Hank I am currently about
two hours into a six-hour flight from
New York City to San Francisco and I'm
sitting in the middle seat I failed to
lay claim to an armrest when we sat down
and now both the people in the aisle and
the window seats are using both arm
rests since they have clearly not
generalized the dear Hank and John movie
theater armrest rule to airplanes do you
have any ideas on how I might acquire
some armrest real estate any dubious
advices appreciated best wishes Lauren
PS the attached picture was taken while
both guys were sleeping I cannot tell
you how anxiety provoking the attached
picture is it's very upsetting to look
at Oh God mmm you know this is why I've
never divorced your father because he
understands the armrest
rule and he's always with me when we fly
okay so one way or another even if
you're in the middle seat you get an
armrest exactly because you're sitting
next to dad yes I think that's a really
good but I mean ah you know we probably
just made Lauren's life worse yeah we
probably did
now she's like great I also don't have
an appliance yeah and I have been in
that situation before and it's just only
I remember mine I was next to a
basketball player so he's very tall
it's a so it was more than just the arm
rest his whole soul modding whole body
yeah but it's hard thing because he's
also having an unpleasant point because
he's probably 680 gonna cope late yes
yes so you add the one on the one hand
you want to be empathetic on the other
hand you are suffering and it's hard
when you're suffering to be empathetic
yes so what would you do in this
situation well you know I actually would
kind of look at both and look for the
more empathetic one and lean over and
ask him for the armor oh you'd ask see
what I would do or sometimes I would put
my arm down gentle now once if there's
like one 1/8 of an inch of the armrest
available for my arm I will put that arm
down and I won't make physical contact
with the person but my arm hair will
make physical contact with his arm hair
brilliant and then they get the nudge
and they're reminded I am in the middle
seat I am the one who deserves these arm
rests
that's Brea thank you thank you I don't
like to brag but that is what I do I do
not I do believe if you are on the aisle
or on the window and you use the middle
seats armrest it's you're a criminal
yeah I think so too
it's just terrible and and I think the
fact that your arm hair would touch
their arm hair is a it's a powerful
statement of creepiness yeah yeah yeah I
don't believe in touching strangers but
I don't mind if my hair touches their
hair okay that just creeps me out
completely sorry have a little shiver
there I'm sorry mom all right we've got
another question that was upsetting I
probably shouldn't have answered that
okay mom we've got a very important
question from Hannah who writes dear
Hank and John my senior prom is swiftly
approaching and I'm having a major
problem first of all her senior prom has
probably passed so sorry Hannah
for not getting this advice to you in
time
I'm sure you did fine first of all how
do you even slow dance
do you just sway back and forth is there
any foot movement how much space should
there be between me and my date where
does my head go help me with my problem
PS you guys should crash my prom sorry
we didn't make it to your prom Hanna but
here is your belated dubious advice on
how to slow dance mom there's a lot of
pause there because you know not so much
do I dance but in my day when I was a
teenager I would practice with my
friends and we would kind of figure out
what was most comfortable for us and and
that's what I would do
how long have you been married 40 years
do you feel comfortable slow dancing
with dad no I really just like it you
just don't like doing it I don't like
dancing in and and no I don't like no
you like it you know that that famous
sort of cliche phrase dance like no
one's watching never has happened to me
in my life that for me the issue is that
if no one's watching I don't want to
dance
exactly yeah I have no desire to be
dancing yeah I also have no desire to be
dancing when people are watching but
like when I'm alone in my room listening
to music I am NOT one to boogie down no
I am however break hey Hank
oh my god Winter Park High School's best
dancer yes he was in 1994 he was voted
best dancer at Winter Park High School
you know I used to introduce Hank
onstage back when when we toured a lot
together and whenever I would introduce
Hank on stage I would list his
accomplishments inventor of 2d glasses
which render three 3d movies in a crisp
two dimensions founder of the
environmental technology blog eco geek
and then I would say that the last thing
I would always say is that in 1990 of
six or whatever he was named best dancer
at Winter Park High School which is true
it is it's absolutely true and
remarkable and he's a good dancer always
a great dancer he and Katherine can uh
yeah we somehow they did not had come to
my half of a family but as I am an
expert in slow dancing
and here's my opinion just go with it
just do what makes you feel comfortable
you should sway back and forth and it's
okay to turn I think in a slow circle so
some foot movement i use usually go in a
in a clockwise circle and then as far as
how much space should be between you and
your date that's really a question of
how comfortable you are with your date
and not something i feel particularly
qualified to weigh in on but i think you
know just um if you're not comfortable
with them it's fine to just hold the
lock lock the elbows yeah I think just
lock the elbows yeah and just do not
touch except hand on waist hand on
shoulders and just keep that physical
distance but if you're comfortable then
you know you can you can touch yeah I
think that the arm lock also is kind of
a sweet look I I don't think that I'm
before I got married I don't recall ever
slow dancing in a way that was had a
whole comfortable yeah me neither
and still I don't love dancing but Sarah
Sarah duck like when we go to wedding
ceramides to dance it got a sass yeah
fortunately your dad still doesn't like
to dance either so that's nice yeah it
is nice I'm a little jealous yeah I wish
I had married dad yeah he's really well
Sarah's nice too yes no I am a fan of
Sarah she's great uh-huh you know we
just celebrated our tenth wedding I know
it's so exciting you know it and it
reminds me of that magical moment of
when we danced and what was the song we
danced to dear well the podcast
listeners know Mom because that's
alright Merle Haggard you did just die
right that pie it was mama tried by
Merle Haggard I read I read the lyrics
to mama try this the short poem that's
right you did I I had it I added Emily
Dickinson poem all lined up and then
Merle Haggard died name-o
oh man alright momma's got another
question this one is from a Keef who
writes dear Hank and John I'm about to
graduate from college I'm an
international student from a developing
nation studying in the US and I've
always planned to go back and use
I've learned over here to help people
back home however recently my parents
have been suggesting I try to get a job
in the US and embark on a more secure
life in a developed country I can see
why they'd want me to do that since
there have been some recent incidents
relating to radicalism back home but I
can't help but wonder if it would be
extremely selfish on my part on the
other hand I've always tried to keep my
parents happy and listen to what they
want me to do thus I am in a dilemma and
in desperate need of some dubious advice
how do I make him understand that we
should sometimes think of the greater
good in a way that they would be
supportive of in my decision
what a big difficult complicated
question I am really curious as your
mother and also knowing you're a father
how you would handle this we don't way
to deflect weight yeah we bring the ball
over to my side of the court yeah you
know the truth is that I don't feel like
we can give great advice here because it
isn't something that I have a lot of
experience with and also because I think
it's it's an incredibly complicated
difficult decision but I thought it was
important to read it on the podcast
because I think it's important to
remember you know the the complexities
of big decisions like that that people
have to face when they're quite young I
mean this is a young person who's about
to graduate from college but has to make
you know a big decision about the rest
of their life when I was traveling in
Ethiopia we got to visit with recently
graduated college students and what
really impressed me was that to a person
they were committed to development they
were committed to you know education
engineering you know fields where they
thought that their talents and the
privileges that they'd had as college
students would really make a big
difference and that's not something that
you see as much I have to say in the
u.s. like when I was graduating from
college it didn't occur to me how can I
serve my country or even really to be
honest how can I serve my community most
of it was can I get a good job that's
gonna
you know allow me to have a good life
and can it be in the world of the Arts
which is the world that I love there was
something kind of selfish about it
looking back I would have made a
terrible mechanical engineer so there is
that but but I just I thought this
question really really captured a
difficult choice that that some people
make that maybe lots of us take the
conclusion for granted yes I really
agree with you on that
the this when you live in such a world
of privilege mmm like you and I
ultimately do it's it's almost
impossible to visualize and certainly
it's impossible to give advice I'm such
a very difficult except to say this is a
time for you and your family to really
join together and in love and an honest
hard discussion I think it's yeah that's
really true somebody told me once that
my privileges were like oxygen and
that's very true it is very difficult to
be aware of one's ones privileges I mean
we all you know have them to one degree
or another but but it becomes almost
impossible to imagine other people's
lives you just it's just it's it's work
and if you don't do that work it's
extremely easy to assume that your life
is normal exactly exactly
all right mom a somewhat less
complicated question okay and I'll be
interested to see if this divides us
okay this question is from Jones who
writes dear Hank and John what is the
proper phrase slice of pizza or piece of
pizza well you know when I was growing
up yeah in Alabama there was no Pete say
exactly is that true well we had to
squeeze pizza which was in in in in
Crestline so you're telling me that when
you were a child there was one pizza
place and yes and mostly your
grandmother would roll out Bisquick and
put some tomato sauce with cheese on it
and call it done so I don't think and
that actually then I had
Pizza and I went huh police really
actually did not know how to make she's
a wonderful woman she was not an expert
Pizza she know she was not that so um
what we say I think can I have a piece
of pizza so you would say piece of pizza
yeah I think that's what I say I also
say piece of pizza probably because
that's what I grew up saying probably
but also because I really like the
alliteration of it it's sort of like
saying hates a pizza yes and I find that
enjoyable okay but I think I know lots
of like in in New York for instance they
refer to slices yes you know always like
can I have a slice and you don't eat
someplace then give you a slice for $2
or whatever
three hours yeah yeah probably maybe
five um I'm always fascinated with the
cultural differences and and were and in
describing things like you know those
things on the stove the little round
things mm-hmm how do you say that I do
not refer to those things I don't have a
word for them I would love to have a
word is you know know the grill know
that turns on turns red cooks the food
it's on top no never known what to call
them the grill the stovetop the burners
the burners I say burners yes and you
know what my mother always said what
Billy gray so I called always called
them the I of the stove oh it's very
like ice that's beautiful yeah I think I
should think we should start calling it
the I of the stove we should bring that
back okay the other regionalism I think
about a lot is that I don't know if this
was true for you when you were a kid in
the south but when I was a kid when
somebody asked me what I wanted to drink
I said a coke and then they said what
kind and then I said a sprite like coke
was the word for so for soda yeah yeah
oh yeah well yes this probably won't
make podcasts but I had a friend whose
job when they graduated from college was
to go around for coke Cola and Tay in
the head he had a good palate and he
tasted coke if somebody said if you he
would go into a restaurant order a coke
and they would say okay and bring him a
coke and if it was a Pepsi he would
write the coke cola company and they
would send a letter to the restaurant
saying you've got to call it Pepsi
because they were trying to make sure
that there was that distinction because
people were starting to call soda Coke
and that what was would affect their
path I think that's fascinating actually
where I'm super interested in trademark
law and one thing that all companies are
terrified of is the generis ization
trademarks yes that's exactly what is it
you're just start calling soda coke then
Coke loses the ability to be the only
thing called coke yes that's why when we
talk about googling people at Google
always talk about search yes they never
use the verb - yes and you've talked
about this before in your podcast do you
do you remember when Hank was on a very
important business call with Yahoo many
many years ago and they were like so I
don't know how familiar you are with
everybody on the call and Hank said oh I
googled all of you and they and then
immediately afterwards this this voice
comes over and she's she said we call it
Yahoo Inc is such a ludicrous it's such
a ludicrous verb hai-yah who do you know
don't worry it's it's almost like a poem
I know you're who you I know your full
resume a yahoo do you now we're going to
go completely off off track okay and
because I'm going to tell the story of
Sarah wanted on one of our first dates
Sharon grew up in the south which he has
northern family yeah so she has a very
interesting accent she always wanted to
sound generically American and not
southern but she grew up around southern
people and this made her a lot of times
put that she still a lot of times puts
the emphasis on the first syllable no
matter what like insurance or umbrella
gay Raj or whatever yeah she doesn't
have an accent yes
does that one trick yes and so when one
of our first date she said something
about
but she she's conscious of it so she's
always trying to like work against it so
she said something about yahoomail what
and she said you know yeah Yahoo the
company and you just wanted to go back
yeah I don't know where you got that
from man that's that's super weird man
all right okay mom let's answer a few
more questions from our listeners before
we get to the exciting news from AFC
Wimbledon and your excellent recipe this
question comes from delenn who asks dear
Hank and John I am afraid of making
phone calls when calling or receiving
calls from my family or my best friend I
feel fine but other stuff freaks me out
when making appointments or calling
strangers I get really nervous and my
stomach is in knots for days I even
sometimes ignore my phone if I'm getting
a call from someone I know
or am friends with I usually text them
later and pretend I was busy but I feel
bad about not answering I also just
really need to make calls every now and
then and I'd like to avoid this hassle
I know doing it is probably the only way
to get over this but how do I start how
do i make myself just call them well I
think as you know John this is probably
my one of my biggest issues with anxiety
and I'm terrible at this
I again you know they're reasons why I'm
married to your dad for 40 years this is
one he'll make phone calls for me and
the armrest we don't know the keys to a
good match you know one person who can
make phone calls and you need to have an
agreement that whoever's in the middle
seat gets the armrest yeah yes and then
the rest will all fall in place terrible
advice it's supposed to be dubious if I
extremely dubious okay fine answer these
two questions and I will marry you no
please don't make a decision based on
those so
yeah so I really struggled with this I
still really struggle with this and one
of the tricks that I do because I really
do get anxious about phone calls is
there are times in the day when I feel
stronger like between 10:00 and 1:00
o'clock or my strongest times
emotionally and mentally and so I will
postpone those phone calls but I'll
write them down and then I will call
between 10:00 and 1:00 and I get the
great joy of putting a line through the
name and that's just one of that's my
trick and and the other is now that I'm
64 I get my permit you can't do this
this is really Dobby as if I have to
wait to your 64 as I give myself
permission to tell people that I'm sorry
that I don't return their phone call and
then communicate through text that's
really not that healthy of a strategy
well I mean maybe it is first you know
you do whatever you need to do I also
feel somewhat anxious about calling
having phone calls with strangers I feel
it much less now than I used to my
anxiety has found other ports in call
but I have to say when I hired rosianna
my amazing brilliant production partner
the first question I asked her is do you
mind calling strangers and she said no I
like calling strangers and that was not
a lie it is an amazing it is amazed to
me it's like she has a superpower yeah
so like if I'm incredibly lucky that if
I if I feel anxious about something like
about a phone call that I have someone
who will make the phone call essentially
make it for me Rosie is your your your
dad yeah I don't know I give her yes I
guess so but so like my mother I have an
anxiety disorder at but
like for instance an incredibly hard
time mailing thinks it's very easy for
me to put the thing in the envelope it's
very easy for me to seal the envelope to
put the stamp on it to write the the
correct name and the return address etc
the part that is difficult is the part
where I walk to the mailbox
I put the item in the mailbox and I and
I lift that little flag that lets the
mail carrier know that I wish to send a
a letter I recognize that this is
ludicrous right that like people can do
this lots of people do it it isn't
physically taxing and I feel the same
way about phone calls in a lot of ways
like it's easy to minimize it because
lots of people can do it because it's
ostensibly very easy to do etc except
that it doesn't matter that it's easy
for other people to do it it doesn't
matter that that it's supposedly not
hard it is hard like it's very hard for
you and you are living inside of the
only consciousness that that you can
live inside of so if I treat it as a
thing that's hard that I am going to do
and that after I finish this hard thing
I will be proud of myself in the way
that I am proud of myself when I do hard
things it somehow becomes easier like I
build up sort of rituals around it I
make it I take it into tiny little steps
you know there's the step of dialing
there's the step of hitting the getting
the call button for me there's the step
of picking up the letter and walking it
out of the house and then there's the
step where I open up the mailbox and
there's a step where I put it in the
step where I close the mailbox where I
raised the flag where I walk back
feeling this immense joy because I have
done this thing that for me is genuinely
difficult and so I think for for me like
that that helps but I think different
things help different people yep mom it
is almost time for us to move on to the
very exciting new segment where you tell
us how to use dr. pepper to make pork
chops is that what we're making
no we're making pork tenderloin pork
pork tenderloin I apologize I not only
do I not know what the eye of the stove
is called I don't even know what a pork
tenderloin is apparently but we just
liked it I loved it no I
up eating pork tenderloin yes I know it
I know about it anyway we have a couple
of responses from previous podcasts that
are very important in addition to the
fact that Tuggle is not dead yeah you
have a couple other updates this from
skip but my college life was I know your
college life is dead I'm sorry mom okay
sorry ah this this update is from skip
who writes dear Hank and John in your
most recent podcast you mentioned the
Yellowstone supervolcano and how John
would like to move to Australia in the
case of an eminent eruption I would just
like to point out that the world's most
active caldera supervolcano is located
in Tasmania there is no escape
oh god there isn't No oh I'm sorry well
the good news mom is that when the
supervolcano comes it will be an
exceptionally slow death because really
we'll end up like all dying of like
starvation because the cloud of Ash will
make it so there is no sunshine and
therefore no crops hmm boy I'm excited
about that possibility
so we'll be desperate yes we'll be
terrified yes there will be no internet
yes and then everything will end okay
then thanks you welcome thanks for
thanks for joining me on the podcast
today and yeah we're going back into
therapy we have one more update this one
is from can't see who writes in replied
to John's thoughts on writing his next
novel completely in emojis mom Dino Dan
emoji I dunno alright there's those
little things that I they're supposed to
mean things do you have a favorite emoji
you use them I do I really and truly
hate all the smiley faces one just on
general principle because they're yellow
and I don't like to color yellow you can
actually change their colors now but go
on
okay well that might make me feel better
um I like the snake one oh yeah you love
snakes you love snakes yeah my mom is a
painter of snakes just a fan of snakes
in general yep not a passion I share
with you so few do I did come across I
was kayaking yesterday and I came across
a small water snake that's perhaps six
inches long and I thought of at least
trying to photograph it for Henry but
then I became very anxious so I didn't
do you remember the time
snake ate your fish at the cabin I do
yeah yeah it was very upsetting we had
had this amazing fishing day yes
incredible like the best fishing day
ever and and then a snake ate ate our
fish it was very upsetting and it was
very gross to watch it happened and it
was a little bit traumatic so my two
main memories from childhood breaking
your cookie jar and the snake eating the
fish
all right anyway this is he such visuals
this is from can't see who writes in
reply to Jon's thoughts on writing his
next novel completely in emojis I wanted
to share that there is already a book by
the artist Zhu Bing that does exactly
that it's called from point to point and
it is a 112 page novel about the
everyday life of an office worker if you
google it you can find images of the
pages it's surprisingly comprehensible
not really a question
just love the podcast Wow isn't that
cool that's very cool we have to look
that up well I did Google some bandages
above it we'll try to put them on the
patreon and let me show I can show you
what it looks like mom okay and we can
show people on the podcast but it is it
is kind of readable it looks like this
isn't that cool oh yeah it's very cool
yeah so it's like I said it is just a
novel in emojis which I do think by the
way I think it's completely legitimate I
know lots of totally yeah I think if you
can use there's all kinds of different
ways to use language and what language
isn't just made of letters that's
absolutely true okay so it's now time to
talk about the news from AFC women I'm
so excited but first what is your recipe
oh my recipe well it's important to know
that where this recipe comes from okay
because it comes from Gracie right my
cousin grace yes and we love the Gracie
is we all like to say so Gracie's
boyfriend tres Barnard he's a chef in
New Orleans he owns a restaurant called
we got soul and I noticed on his menu
that he prints weekly that he had some
pork tenderloin that was marinated in
your favorite soda mm-hmm
dr. pepper dr. pepper well it must last
time yeah you don't know of dr. pepper I
feel like it's a it's a little too rich
for my palate yes all right
diet dr. pepper not as good of a
marinade no but but you have to have
that richness for a good marinade so you
have to use you have to really use the
straight stuff all right so it's pork
tenderloin yep
marinated in dr. pepper and brown sugar
and crushed red pepper and a vanilla
bean and bay leaves and you can cook you
cook it which is kind of fun to cook dr.
pepper it bubbles a lot and and reduce
it by half cool it off put the pork in
there let it marinate for at least eight
hours and then grill it and it ban test
it I have to say I was deeply impressed
I was too I had rice he's a good he's a
good chef I had low expectations but I
was very very impressed today's podcast
oh it's brought to you by yeah dr.
pepper I'm not only good for your taste
but good for your soul oh there we go
that's a nice advertisement for Tracy's
restaurant and today's podcast is also
brought to you by the middle seat the
middle seat you have the right to both
the arm rests and do it via touching arm
hair if necessary whatever it takes and
this podcast is brought to you by the
end of college the end of college it
doesn't really end until you lose your
cookie jar and lastly because podcast is
brought to you by a supervolcano set to
erupt at any moment in Tasmania or
possibly the United States we have
essentially no way of knowing or if we
do have a way of knowing we don't have a
science person on the podcast right now
to tell us that we should be calm about
this so we're going to panic okay that
sounds like a good strategy for the two
of us all right mom okay the news from
AFC Wimbledon is that as this podcast is
aired I will be in London who Rosie
Alana and your husband my dad and a few
other people from here in Indianapolis
at Wembley Stadium a 90,000 C
Stadium where AFC Wimbledon will be
playing in the playoff final for all the
marbles right now as I'm talking AFC
Wimbledon has a 50% chance of having a
100% chance of becoming a third tier
English soccer team next year the game
is just it's incredibly exciting it's
almost impossible to contextualise how
unlikely this is for instance AFC
Wimbledon has the smallest Stadium in
league to the league they're currently
in really yeah Kent Kingsmeadow is the
smallest stadium in League Two and yet
somehow they have found their way one
victory against Plymouth Argyle from
then having the smallest Stadium in
Ligue 1 I'm really really excited I mean
obviously I desperately hope that AFC
Wimbledon win the game if you see me in
at Wembley please feel free to say hi it
would be it would be great to to be able
to meet you thanks to I know lots of
dear Hank and John listeners are going
to the game at Wembley which is so cool
thank you for getting on board with my
eccentric passion for this Football Club
but I talked to in the last couple days
I've talked to both the the founding
commercial director of the club and the
CEO and they're just they're so excited
they're so excited to be nerdfighters
club they're so excited to be playing at
Wembley and I'm just I'm looking forward
to having a great day out no matter what
happens because it is already wonderful
to have made it to Wembley it's a
massive massive deal for the club both
in terms of you know coverage and
financially and everything but obviously
it will be an especially great day out
if if the improbable happens and and
Wimbledon go up it would just be
absolutely magical that's such a great
great story I'm so excited that you guys
are going I know your dad is just really
thrilled and the good news is he'll be
there to keep you calm at all times and
if you need to make a phone call he's
not only that and he'll mail a letter
for you he'll mail a letter for me I
feel like dad will probably give me the
armrest yes an emergency yes you will
so yeah he's a good he's a good guy art
I was gonna say our dad but he's not
he's not your dad yeah um but I'm used
to talking to Hank mom thank you so much
for joining me on today's episode of
dear Hank and John you've been my
favorite guest host ever and the only
one that has ever had but it's still my
favorite thanks and thanks to everybody
for listening we really appreciate it
today's podcast is edited by nicholas
jenkins our intern is claudia morales
rosianna halse rojas helps us out with
questions if you want to ask us a
question you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com or use the hashtag on
Twitter dear Hank and John if you wanna
ask my mom a question you can do that as
well
you can just use the same hashtag and
I'll have her look for it but thanks
again for listening
our theme music is by gonna roll up I
always forget the music is by gunnarolla
you can follow us on Twitter
I am at John Green Hank is at Hank green
mom what's your Twitter you don't really
remember I don't hold on I'll look it up
or I'll look it up for you I think it's
mom blonde Buffy's mom blog brother it
is it's confirmed to be mom vlogbrothers
right now on top of her Twitter feed you
can see a snake skin he's not kidding
about the snakes people that's how I
decorate yeah it's beautiful it looks
great thanks again for listening and as
we say in my hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]